agents
what am i supposed to do confirm with
them every 15 minutes what's that
okay do you want to come no take it like
i'm saying
right now anywhere none of your business
but do you know how much rent he pays i
don't know
thanks for nothing it's dark it's late
we're in the hood
i ain't gonna lie guys yesterday was a
tough day
we had it was a long long day we started
it like 6 30 in the morning and we were
still going at one 2 o'clock in the
morning
[Music]
so we're on our way now to stratton
island to view some apartments
we've got some um great brokers that
we've made friends with
in the new york area
[Music]
so anyway i just thought i'd quickly
send you my love so say bye to ruby
and luke
luke's not off playing hello luke we
went to look at some properties in
staten island
which is really close to new york good
to see you
and they were fantastic and we were
really excited about the properties
can make good returns you can get really
discounted properties
and to be honest i probably could sell
those properties to some investors
but the problem of doing that is at the
end of these seven days i don't want to
make
three four five or even ten thousand
pounds this week
this week i want to buy a house using
none of my own money what do you think
possibly
the lowest they will accept and still
live with would they
i mean i would probably go in at about
sort of
145 150 see if they take it
yeah how much did this happen for last
year oh a lot more
um you're probably looking up like one
eight um i want to say
yeah 180s 200 really yeah so let's do
this
yeah potentially now we could go into
maybe yeah possibly
and then we'd buy if we bought it cash
we'd rent it for about 15 1600. yeah
uh if we rented it for about 1600 pay
all the
um charges 600 a month so we might be
left
i love the apartment i think it's really
good if if you were
us and you were buying in the united
states of america or this area
what would you personally invest in what
would you buy i throw money probably
into st
george area right now because it's
definitely booming and it's coming up
um there's also a house down there that
i've seen it's listed at 345
it's on winter avenue right nobody right
now nobody wants to touch it because
no one wants to check well because it's
a little bit dicey the neighborhoods
but in terms of appreciation value just
up the same road you've got new homes
that were sold for like seven four five
how much would you buy for now
um you might be able to get it for a
little bit less
um it's three four five four three four
five how many did you rent it for
um well i'd rent it room by room maybe
oh i like this
you've got the keys for it i don't have
the keys for it unfortunately because i
can show us the outside talking about i
can take you through the outside yeah
so you think if you spent a little bit
of money on it and then you rent it out
room by room
yeah that's it could be juicy that's it
it's probably got a few of them
you know so you're thinking for this buy
it for around about you know 350 freezer
whatever you can get it for and then
refurb it yeah rent it out in a room by
room who
who would rent this and who would be the
sort of i mean
at the moment it would probably be
someone who's government subsidized yeah
and how much rent would they would the
council pay for one of the rooms
800 800 a month yeah for just one room
yeah and how many rooms would you get
here
um well this is a full bed one bath i
think it was that they said
so you reckon you get about four people
yeah but i mean i don't know
maybe you could do something inside
where the room's so big you can get
another room out of there
alistair you wanted to ask a little bit
about the rules and regulations of doing
this regarding obviously in the uk
yeah when you do roomies or hmos yeah
obviously loads of legislation
right um do you know what that is is
there much yeah i mean
the only thing that you'll have to do
they come out and they do an inspection
of the home so they were checking for
simple things like
sometimes um window rings like you see
that house over there on the
uh you'd call it second floor okay
right but the um that they have like a
window guards up so you need to put that
sort of thing in place
you would need to put up smoke alarms
carbon monoxide
fire safety
so what i'm thinking right now is i
think that
this area stan island it's fantastic
we've got a great relationship with an
agent now which is brilliant
the problem is to do what we're wanting
to do
like a buy now pay later or a joint
venture or something i just think we're
going to struggle
wholesaling would work really well here
with an agent like amy
but we've got more houses to see now in
philadelphia which is going to be a
different beast again so we're just
we've done new york now we've done
staten island um time to go
time to go and do new jersey and
philadelphia and pennsylvania
oh i'm excited i want to buy man now the
only way
that i can buy a house using no money
while i'm here
in the united states of america is
number one is finding a joint venture
partner so finding a property that is
so so good that someone
who i also have to find as well as the
property is prepared
to put all of the money in and give me a
profit share of that property
maybe 50 maybe 25 so that would be a way
where i could get my foot in the door
buy a property or part of a property
without using any money
which is awesome the other way to do it
would be by buying a property
whereby you buy it now but you pay for
it later
we call this a lease option agreement
because you have the
option to pay for it later even though
you buy it now
now the great thing about that is if you
get the right property in the right area
when you have to pay for it later which
could be five or ten years down the line
the property has gone up in value so you
get a bargain price for it down the line
but also you immediately because you buy
it now
even if you haven't paid for it you
immediately control the property and
benefit as if you were the owner
so you get capital appreciation but you
also can put a tenant in there and start
getting rent i'm gonna try and find a
property
whereby the area is bottomed out and
people are struggling to sell
there's negative equity which means that
the mortgages are so high
and the values are sometimes lower than
the mortgages so there's no equity in
the property
the sellers are really struggling and
they're the kind of properties that i'm
going to be looking for which i won't
find in new york
because the bottom line is if you want
to make money you've got to solve
people's problems
and where everything's rosy and
everyone's happy and everyone's making
money
it's actually harder even though in new
york everyone's making money
it's harder for people like me to get
into a market like that and make money
it's easier for me to go into an
industry or a market where people are
struggling
people are suffering there's problems
because then you can solve those
problems
and then you can start making money
what's awesome about america and about
the new websites there are advertising
properties
such as zillow and trivia it is when the
listings go on it gives you the full
address
now it lets you do a bit of research and
you can find the properties that are
negative equity so tonight and tomorrow
we're sitting down and we're finding
lots of viewings we're going to go out
knocking on people's doors tomorrow and
we're going to be contacting people
directly
trying to help vendors and see how we
can help them because at the end of the
day they're in negative equity they're
stuck they can't get anywhere
if we can offer them a situation a
solution to their problem
it's a win-win for every party surely
and that's how we're going to get a
direct defender lead
so that's my plan it might work it might
completely not
but let's just drive down to
philadelphia and see what we can do
in west philadelphia born and raised on
the playground is where i spend most of
my days
chilling out maxin relaxing all cool and
all shooting some b-ball
outside of the school when a couple of
guys who were up to no good
started making trouble in my
neighborhood i got in one little fight
and my mom got scared i said you're
moving with your auntie and uncle in
ballet i'm an agent
so i sell houses uh so i'm licensed in
pa
only for now i don't i don't have a
license in new york or new jersey
so just the just the pennsylvania
area yes so um investment properties
yeah buy week like buy hold rent out to
tenants
it's a roller coaster yeah from one
neighborhood to another
neighborhood you know like blocks to
block yes it's like yes
especially i don't know in new york but
uh center city of philadelphia
the rent to own program was that how did
that come about did that come back but
it was a government incentive
this program doesn't work with investors
because
with this side to the business but if
someone's in um
negative equity so they own they owe
more to the bank
yeah then the house is worth and they
can't sell yeah that's when we
offer a lease option so we'll say we'll
buy it and we give them a prize
okay okay okay okay what are you saying
okay
yeah there's the people yeah there is a
people like that i don't know i don't
know she understands yeah police option
agreements
she gets it but the problem is it's the
same as the uk
the thing is honestly she knows
that she won't get her faith yeah you
know are the people in this area of
negative equity
she didn't even go there she didn't want
to tell us i told the truth she didn't
even go there because she knows that
we'll go straight to them yeah
but she's she's just thinking of in her
the way they do things and the way they
run their business
that's why i think we need to go to
vendors direct here's here's the
interesting thing when we get a proper
nobody down downloads option agreement
and explain how we did it yeah everyone
in america is going to start doing it
crazy
everyone's going to start doing this no
one's doing it at the moment
491 234
properties for sale it's almost half a
million
so if we narrow this down just a little
bit that's our patch
so in philadelphia and that side of new
jersey there's just 186
let's narrow this down more we do not
want agent no
no agent we just want buy own that
only and there are 333 or
some of these are pretty expensive so
let's do a filter let's say
to a maximum of one hundred thousand
dollars
there's a hundred and twelve ah get more
info that's how you get their number
and then is it the one at the top is
that the no that's the agent isn't it
uh property owner property owner
all right let's phone them see what we
can do
your call has been forwarded to an
automated voice messaging system
[Music]
please leave your message your call has
been forwarded to an automatic voice
message
i promise if i leave voice messages by
the time
they phone me back it might be too late
i could be back in the uk with no deal
by the time
[Music]
are you kidding me
mate you know those viewings that we
bought yesterday did i confirm that view
yesterday
yeah yeah i've just texted him
and he said you've confirmed too late i
cannot show you now today
i confirmed it with him yesterday sergi
you probably
were you filming me when i confirmed
that yesterday i confirmed it yesterday
at 11 00
at 11am so both of our agents have now
said that when we confirm what what am i
supposed to do confirm with them every
15 minutes
yeah we sent my text message yesterday
at seven what does he want me to do this
is why i
hate agents what happened to
your word being your bond when you just
make an appointment and then you just
both
show up what happened to that i must
have i must have phoned made a hundred
phone calls yesterday to get that
appointment
and now he said oh you confirmed too
late i think we need i think we just
need some
fast viewings today with with friggin um
vendors direct why don't we on zillow
full addresses why don't you go knocking
on doors knocking on doors of people
that have the house versailles or just
of anybody
for sale so if they have the house for
sale we knock on the door they know
they're selling their houses
yeah because they're on sale yeah so
let's just rock up knock on the doors
and see what happens
yeah yeah all right that one that one i
know i've seen a lot of win
so why don't we just go not the door i'm
do man do you want to come
no are you kidding me it's your
challenge
oh mate all right nice to know you buddy
it's terrible weather for this we better
do it quickly all right let's go okay
i'll wait
this isn't even rain i thought it was
right this
oh how much did it sell for i don't know
you know sure do you know how much
roughly
do you know how much roughly what's that
okay
hi sorry to bother you um i just think i
was just coming to see about your house
i was noticing the
um so you look a bit confused sorry
yeah i was just you've got your house
for sale this ain't for sale
no no so
no i can't help you i'm sorry are you
renting
none of your business okay
no i'm not interested i just told you
man
this is my brother's house okay do you
know how much not in the western is
selling no
do you know how much rent he pays that's
all right yeah that's right
all right take it like i'm saying we're
not interested
yeah okay but do you know how much rent
he pays i don't know
it will literally take two minutes i'm
very very interested in buying this
house i haven't been able to get hold of
the agent
i'm sorry make an appointment next time
sorry guys
i can see another there's a for sale
sign up here right here
oh man come on seriously jason how many
doors are we going to knock on
well we're getting nowhere
seriously man it's dark it's late we're
in the hood
you're going to get yourself shot mate
you're not on these people's doors
middle of night you're going to get
yourself shot
i don't want to go back without a deal
yeah i want to get a deal
and then we can go back i get that back
to the hotel until i speak to someone
who's prepared to give me that house man
i'm just not freaking going back you're
going to be doing it all night man i'm
seriously and people ain't going to be
answering the doors
oh man let's just see let's just say a
white dude in a suit in the middle of
[ __ ]
the hood they ain't answering the door
what do you suggest i suggest we go
faster we just keep going into a good
deal come on man come on man
come on seriously man two more two more
how many deals did you get then
you